JUSTIN: Hi, my
name is Justin Koh
and I'm an engineer on
the Android Wear team.
I'm here today to
tell you about how
you can make your app ready for
the wrist with Android Wear.
Let's take a look at how
developing for Android Wear
is different than developing
traditional Android apps.
One key benefit of Android
Wear is giving people
the information they need
right when they need it.
We realize that your
Android device already
does a lot of this
through notifications,
so we decided to
start by bringing
those same notifications
to your wrist.
I'll show you what I mean.
Here I have my Nexus 5.
I've installed the Android
Wear preview app on it,
and I've paired it to
my emulated device.
I have a small app which
creates notifications
with different styles.
Notice how the notification
appears on Android
Wear automatically.
I can update the
notification, and the changes
are immediately bridged over.
Even better, I can dismiss the
notification from my Android
Wear device and it'll
disappear from my phone.
This is a really
powerful concept.
This means that if your app
posts notifications today it's
already on your wrist.
It's worth noting
that all of this
is possible thanks to the
Notification Listener API
that was added in Android 4.3.
So let's talk about
how to get started
developing for Android Wear.
First go to
developer.android.com
where you can sign up
for the developer preview
and browse the documentation.
You should also download
the system image
from the SDK manager to create
an Android virtual device
with Android Wear.
Finally, install the
Android Wear preview app
and run it on your
Android phone that
is connected to your emulator.
At this point you'll have
your development environment
set up and ready to go.
Let's look at some code for
an app that invites people
to events.
It probably looks
really familiar right?
There isn't anything specific
to Android Wear here.
I'm just using the
NotificationCompat class
from the Android support
library to show a notification.
I've also added an
action to my notification
so I can tell my app that
I'll be attending the event.
This action becomes
available on my wrist
so I don't even have
to take my phone out
of my pocket to respond.
Instead I just swipe over to
the right and tap the action.
That starts a
service on the phone
that can add the
event to my calendar
and then remove
the notification.
Note that I could have used the
notification styles introduced
in Android 4.1 such
as Big Picture style
to show a photo alongside
the notification text.
So that's really cool,
but with great power
comes great responsibility.
Automatically bridging
notifications to your wrist
means it's extremely
important that you
be considerate of when and
how you notify the user.
First, note that Android
Wear devices will not
vibrate for every notification.
That would get annoying
really quickly.
Only notifications which
would vibrate or make
a sound on the phone
will buzz your wrist.
Next, it's important
that notifications
be as contextually
relevant as possible.
For example, you can use the
API's in Google Play services
to set up a geofence and
only post a notification when
the user is at home.
Or you could use the Activity
Detection API to only send
notifications when
the user is biking.
If you have an
app that generates
a lot of notifications,
like a chat or email client,
you should give
your user control
over when your notifications
will make a sound or vibrate.
Finally, you should take
advantage of the notification
priority field.
There are several buckets, max,
high, default, low, and min.
Setting the proper
priority helps
the system show the most
relevant information
at the right time.
For more on what makes
a good notification
see the design guidelines
on developer.android.com.
So that's one way
you can begin getting
your app ready for the
wrist with Android Wear.
By optimizing your
app's notifications
you'll be taking the
first step to making
your app more wrist friendly.
There are more API's in
the developer preview that
will help you
customize notifications
when they appear on
Android Wear devices.
So check out the documentation
in other DevBytes episodes
for more on that.
And make sure to look at the
sample code in the developer
preview and the UX guidelines
on developer.android.com.
Thanks and happy coding.